I have to go to bed.
Uh uh uh uh uh.
to the stream. I'm not feeling so good today. By that I mean my tummy hortie. My tummy hortie.
So I may have some extra idol meetings I have to go to. But we're still gaming. Thank goodness
this is an easier game. Am I right? Easier game. It's so stressful. It's so stressful.
Okay, okay. So what was what was that that we did last time? Okay, so we found Christy.
We found Christy. We brought her back to the mansion. She has she has a deathmark. She doesn't
want to die anymore. And we ran away from the big giant bee man. Understood. By the way,
there's one thing I'd like to confirm. When I stayed here earlier, you told me the truth
you're seeking can be found here. I really doubt this. But do you know the honey bee family had
something to do with these marks? His voice shakes slightly with anger. The drama.
But it doesn't faze Mary a bit. I do not have such power.
I simply sense that your fate was entwined with Lord Darlings.
I do not know what truth you were seeking, Lord Mashita. But if you remain near Lord Darlings,
I predict that you will find it more culpable. Mashita clicks his tongue.
That's just that's that's tongue clicking. Empires, can you click your tongue?
No, not well, I can. I feel like because I can't whisper, I have the ability to click my tongue.
I can sound like a ping pong thing.
I would only speak in only tongue clicks if it were socially acceptable. I think tongue clicks
is considered rude. So I don't do it much. Thank you for the five super.
I can't click my tongue you cut it out after I talk back to you remember. Oh yeah, stay mute.
Mercy, can you wish my Serata crit for it? Because when it does become Serata,
where therefore it will be, please bless me. What does this mean? What does this mean?
Am I blessing? Am I blessing your like, gotcha rolls?
Am I blessing your gotcha roll? By the power of mercy. Chippos, go!
I don't know if it works, sorry.
Got your rolls not guaranteed.
But he isn't scowling anymore, so his curiosity must be satisfied.
What do they have to do with anything?
I just owe them. I just owe them, that's all. Mashita falls silent saying nothing more.
I guess he doesn't want to tell me.
Okay, who's our partner? Let's do Kristi Arimura. Yeah, let's go with her blah blah blah. What's in
my bag? Baseball bat. Sho had. It's covered in scratches and dents. I've seen a lot of use
off the baseball field, only Sho can use it. Okay. Baseball, or in baseball that Sho had in
his pocket and may be scratched, but the ball itself has been polished white. It's obviously
well maintained. Honey Bee Family Note 2, a torn out of a book of H- I don't know about that,
a T- point out of a book. In one of the cottages, honey bees are friends. Make them friendly with
medicine from the sprayer. If they get mad, pay attention to the direction the hive is facing.
Awakened, honey bees leave the hive in their direction of the sun. Okay, I feel like
pay attention to the direction the hive is facing. Let me write this down Senpai.
Pay attention.
Hive facing mad and awake.
E. Direction of sun. Senpais, you know which direction the sun sets and the sun rises.
Because I totally don't remember.
Sets in the west, rises in the east. Okay.
Oh, we can see the sun? Yeah, you can see it. Every once in a while.
Remember, Japan east is the land of the rising sun. Oh, that's a good way to remember it.
Let's see.
Okay, page torn out of a book in one of the cottages, make hive new bodies, smear honey all
over, ferment honey, get stinky liquid.
Drawn by smell, honey bee enter hive. We got the sprayer, the broken curl bar, and we're done.
Small pressure sprayer. If attached to bottle, you are able to spray drugs. Because of the type
of nozzle, it can't spray very far. It cannot be used on its own. Haddable bottles of medicine
must be inserted first. Broken curl bar. Well, shit, it's broken. The curl bar was broken when
used to force a door open. It's not much left in it now, making it hard to use. The broken
edge is sharp and dangerous to touch. We can use it still, stabby wubby.
And then handgun, a police revolver handed over by Mashita. The only bullets left are in the
cartridge. Anyone without any training will have difficulty aiming. Only Mashita can use it.
Man, shoot. Anything else? Let's go over Shimeo again. Okay.
Okay, okay, we're doing a recap Senpai. Sorry, I'm doing a recap so I can remember all the hints.
Okay, the forest in Shimeo, known as the Spotted Man or Shimeo, he's covered in dark
splotches and asks all he meets if they like bees. Do you like bees? If they say yes, he attacks them
while laughing maniacally. He sounds like you're standard crazy, but I guess he's the next spirit
we'll face at any rate. We'll have to head to the forest to investigate.
Man at the brink of suicide. As we walk past the grave marker, an agitated man named Masao
Kimura appears. Once we got him to calm down, he calls off his plans to kill himself.
Before he leaves, he mentions seeing a man covered in dark splotches. I wonder if he's
still around? We should keep moving. Carps in the Cottage. We find a corpse in a burlap sack,
in a cottage in the forest. The strange body is completely covered in what appears to be honey.
It doesn't look like suicide, but who'd do this and why? The cottage is oddly clean,
so someone might be coming here every day. Could it be the culprit?
Maintain a sprayer. I find a sprayer that can shoot a variety of liquids. Then I hear the strange
ghost-like voice again. Manipulators will themselves be manipulated. It keeps coming
out of nowhere and surprising me, but I must admit it has never once lied to me. Maybe it's not
actually an evil spirit. Mysterious Shrine. As we are investigating the forest that black rabbit
appears, I quickly chase after it and arrive in an old, leaning torii gate. Is there a shinto shrine
past it? I'd love to investigate, but hives over the gate poured off intruders will have to look
elsewhere for now. A marked bearer in a cottage. We quiet the bees with the spray and find a
second cottage further in the forest. No corpse inside this time, but a living woman named Kristi
Adimura. A former news anchor. Seems she came to commit suicide, but getting caught up with us in
our circumstances changed her mind. Oddly enough, she already bears the mark. What irony. She most
likely got her mark from Shimiyu while we're discussing it. The flashlight goes out. It's not
malfunctioning. It's just like with Hanehiko. A presence is closing in on the cottage when we
have to get out of here. We have no time to explore and we definitely can't get lost. The shortest
route back to the forest entry entrance is the only way. Temporary retreat. Somehow we get to the
car. We get the car started and speed out of the forest. Before we make it out, we spot two men.
One of them familiar. It was Kimura. His neck twisted awkwardly. He seems dead. The man next
to him was smiling. Was that Shimiyu? The disembodied voices controlled those that are different and
exercised them. Easy for them to say. How do I even do that? We learn another truth on her drive back
to the mansion. Mashita, who escaped the mark once already, now has it again. It appears that he
saw what we think is Shimiyu. It's true, then. The spirits are the ones cursing people with the
mark. But it's beyond me why Mashita would risk his life to learn more about the mark. It must
have some kind of reason. Temporary retreat. Back at the mansion, Christy tells us of an incident
in the forest she reported on back when she was an anchor. Five years ago, a group of people calling
themselves the Honey Bee family lived cut off from society deep in the forest. That is until one day
when they mysteriously committed mass suicide. News reports said they become disillusioned with
society and followed their leader's orders to die. But the police investigation was inconclusive.
The problem lies with the appearance of the leader who was said to have died with him. Christy
says pictures showed him to be a giant obese man. The mass suicide caused the forest to become quickly
deserted. This Honey Bee family group concerns me. There were traces of their presence everywhere in
the forest. If you want to survive any unexpected dangers or chance encounters with Shimiyu,
we need to be careful not to overlook a single detail in this investigation.
Yeah, that's it.
Okay, let's save again.
And get out of here.
We come to the forest entrance once again.
That man is gone, it seems. I look at the old picnic food.
What was Shimiyu doing back then? Making a corpse sit next to him. It's almost like he was having a picnic.
Just one of them? What do you mean? Nothing, sorry. Just talking to myself. Don't worry about it.
Let's go. We haven't learned anything about him yet.
And try changing the subject, but I still can't stop staring at the picnic table.
Okay. Anything new here?
I don't think it's been used in a long time. There's no garbage loaded around either.
If you're around inside the container, my fingers hit something hard.
Got an empty bottle. Nice. There's something else too. Pick it up. It's a crumpled piece of paper
with Lee family fun play cat. Liquid got on to keep these gather over and over game interrupted.
That's all it says. Is this a diary draft or something?
I thought honeybee family draft.
Oh, at least he threw it in the garbage, I think. Okay, let's go in.
Maybe she can read the stuff. Look, something's written in magic marker.
Maybe opposite of the truth, you'll be followed. See the entrance of the beast trail off to the side.
I want to go. Do you remember the second cottage we went to, Senpai? I want to go to that one first.
No spooks. Don't spook me.
Yeah, there was more stuff there, so I'm gonna go there. That's where we found the lady. Yeah.
Something's written in Sanskrit, but the letters are blurry. It looks just like a stain.
Let's see the entrance to a beast trail off to the side.
There's the gray marker, but nothing's unusual about it. See the entrance?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, I got it. Okay, let's go here then.
I think we go here. These are quiet here.
I think it's over on this side.
Yep, there it is. There's the easel statues. Go in!
I opened the notebook, but most of the pages have been ripped out.
Doubt it has anything useful.
Open the notebook, but most of the pages have been ripped out.
Okay, well, useless then. I take all of these. The cabinet is packed full of bottles.
Everything's coated in thin layer of dust. Most of the containers are empty.
I search through the containers and gather ones that have something in them.
Got night night times three.
Yeah, drugs. What about this one?
It looks like maybe a mouse chewed a hole in this plastic container. It's unusable. Shit.
Holy fuck, that scared the shit out of me.
It was an accessory case. This exquisite,
the crafted case. The jewelry inside looks out of place sitting in this cottage.
Thought that was my door. I was like...
Well, there's nothing warning us, so it's probably just fucking sound. Fucking game.
Sometimes gives me like the jump scares.
I open it. There are carefully preserved torn notebook pages inside.
It's a holy journey performed in a quiet place.
In the area past the meeting place, there's a clue about how to get to paradise.
Eastern thickets often got Honey Bee Family Note 3.
Thought this game was relaxing. I did. I said,
yeah, this is a relaxing game. That's super stressful. Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I need a drink my tea.
Somebody hold me senpai. Please hold senpais together.
Okay, let's get out of there and hopefully we don't, we don't, you know, run into Shimeo.
Any bitches here? No bitches?
I'm gonna go straight. I don't think.
Meeting place. Hold on, I'm looking at the items again.
Make hive, new body smear all over.
Play catch.
Area past the meeting place. A clue how to get paradise.
Eastern thickets often.
Well, we're gonna move forward.
The buzzing of bees fills the area. Looks like there's another giant beehive here.
Probably wouldn't be wise to go in without doing something about them first.
Look what I have. I take out the sprayer.
I should be able to use it to spray drugs.
Yeah, drugs.
One night night. Oh wait, no. Was that not it?
Wait, I could have saved. I could have saved.
I could have saved the entire time in this area.
Son of a bitch.
I've been running back to the mansion each time.
Oh, I bet you knew. Shut up.
Shut up.
Okay, well, we'll spray him.
Kill him.
We'll use night night.
I take out night night and put it in the sprayer.
Take careful aim and spray the drug.
The bees movement gets slower. We didn't want a back seat.
I mean, it would have helped.
Eventually the hive falls completely silent.
Used up one bottle of night night.
I've silenced every hive in this area. Now we can pass through.
Pesticides are bad for you.
I know. I know. You want, you want some bees in your face.
No, I don't think so.
Shut up, Christy. Give me a second. I'm gonna move my microphone.
Shut up, Christy. We're doing this for our own safety.
Be careful not to breathe any in. You'll get asthma.
Is that how it works?
Hello, let's go in.
Oh, shut the fuck up.
I hear creaks and groans along with the wrestling of leaves.
There you are.
Now, which way do I go?
Map. Do I have a map?
Do I go left or right some pie? What do you think?
Right. Okay.
What's this?
Don't make, don't make weird sounds. Don't make weird sounds.
There's a thicket growing straight ahead. Look.
Rather dense. There's no way to see what's past it.
Beel.
Pressed through the thick undergrowth.
Notice a small clearing inside.
The path might keep going. I realize something as I continue down it.
He said I'm a hawk.
Ghost, don't scare.
Is that Reno?
I can feel someone staring at me from the bushes.
I'll fight you. I've got, I've got drugs.
I've got a sprayer and I've got two fingers to go in one eye.
I'm too much of a coward.
Hey, Christy.
Can you handle it for me?
Please try it.
Me?
Christy, you do it.
You in Utah.
I, I guess I'll have to.
She faces the figure and offers up a prayer.
No way it worked.
Ah, let me just tell you being a coward has its perks.
I didn't believe in her either, but it worked.
The figure vanishes.
It, it disappeared.
Have a little faith, Mercy. I didn't think that would work. I was a fucking coward.
It seemed her desperate prayer worked.
Thank goodness.
It didn't possess me.
Good job, I think.
I don't know.
I don't know how it worked.
Let's keep going.
Holy shit, is that?
The diesel statue is damaged from being exposed to the elements for so long.
Can I touch it?
Is that motherfucking blood?
I don't like that senpai.
I don't want to.
That's, that's so blood, isn't it?
It's a wooden door.
Look, the door here is in that damage. No need for me to break it open.
Can I, why isn't my, my X button working?
I can't save.
Suppose I can't save.
It's okay.
College door is locked.
Son of a bitch.
Well, I can't go there anymore.
Um.
Let's move forward.
Should we go left or what was, should we go straight or right?
Straight, right?
Didn't say it wasn't locked.
Yeah, said it was.
Let's go straight.
The buzzing of bees fill the area.
Looks like there's another giant beehive here.
Probably wouldn't be wise to keep going without doing something about them first.
I take out the sprayer and hold it in one hand.
Should be able to use it to spray drugs.
We have enough.
Oh no!
Hey, the wrong button I hit feel!
Uh, tool.
Night night.
I'll take out night night and put it in the sprayer.
A careful, I take careful aim and spray the drug.
The bees movements get slower.
Eventually the hive falls completely silent.
Used up one bottle of night night.
Shit.
I don't have enough drugs.
Need one more.
Where do I get one more?
Well, I'm sure we'll find more.
Well, I gotta choose one of these, I guess.
It's probably an empty bottle.
We can figure out how to make,
make, uh, new night night.
We have to cook, yeah.
Yeah, there's one more.
Okay, we can't continue on.
Maybe it's in the lock shifter?
Probably.
We'll have to find something then.
I think we went this way yet.
Did we?
No, we didn't.
Hello?
A sweet fragrance wafts from the,
on the wind from somewhere in the darkness.
At my feet are what looks like beehives.
There must be what remains of a bee farm.
Why are they so fit?
Weird.
It's like this is here of all places.
Okay, uh, if they're mad.
Um, pay attention to the direction the bees are facing.
Okay, left, right, south.
Awake, bees are awake in the direction of the sun.
East, that's the last one.
Okay, let's figure this out.
Well, may as well have a look around.
I don't like that.
Gangling from the tree are human corpses.
The skin is as white as wax.
Countless holes are drilled in the bodies and bees are buzzing in and out of them.
My mind flashes to the corpse in the cottage.
It's just like that one.
Christy is looking away.
How horrible.
Why would anyone do this?
The beehive at my feet starts to rattle.
Oh, no.
A pitch black cloud suddenly rises up, overwhelming my vision.
Something invades my eyes and nose.
It's a swarm of bees?
Oh, oh, girls, oh, madma bees!
Eek!
No, stay away from me!
Oh, fuck!
Live or die!
Even more bees are coming from the hives.
Oh, fuck.
Which hive should I close first?
Wait, what?
What do you mean, which hive should I close first?
Oh, thank you, secret, for the five gifted.
Ah!
The one at your feet, so the middle one.
So the south one, right?
Okay.
Yeah, close the one by your feet first.
Okay, yeah, they are directions just like how the story said.
I have been somehow managed to close the lid, but...
These descend from me from all sides.
They must have swarmed from out from another beehive.
Ah, it was wrong!
Check for more active hives.
What do you mean?
Ah!
Ease?
I dive at the hive and close the lid.
I hear the disgusting sound of bees being crushed.
I guess I was able to steal the hive in time.
Okay, okay.
I might die.
I might die, Senpai.
I might die, so the first one was not self.
So this one was east.
The second one is east, is correct.
There's only one left.
I carefully sneak close to the hive
and manage to close the lid.
Lukewarm liquids burst everywhere, like a grape bursting in my hand.
Seeding closing the hive
right before the bees barked out of it.
Still safe?
Check for more active hives.
What?
After I close all the little hives,
the bees finally quiet down.
I survived!
That was my bad.
That was close.
Yeah, you're telling me.
That was probably east.
West.
There's probably east, west, then south.
Oh, man.
Right, because of the sun direction.
But how would we know which one to have closed?
Would have been where the sun rises,
the sun sets, and then whatever.
East, south, then west.
Why would it be south?
And then west.
West.
We crouch there for a while
until we catch our breath.
Clockwise on a compass.
In between rise and set.
Oh, right, like a clock.
Wow, I'm stupid.
Right.
That makes sense.
You're right. Wow.
I didn't even think about that.
It's okay, I saw bees and I was like,
Ah, bees!
Do I dare touch the bees?
Look.
There are countless holes drilled in them.
The holes seem to have a spiral pattern.
Must have been intentional.
A thick liquid drips from them.
The smell. I can't describe how horrible it is.
The bees are gathering on it.
What's that liquid?
Seems that liquid attracts bees.
I had a suitable container.
I could gather some of it.
The stinky liquid!
I take out the empty bottle and gather some of the dripping liquid in it.
That's stinky liquid.
Nothing seems out of ordinary.
Looks like a normal beehive.
Open the beehive.
There's a bottle of drug amongst the form.
A large bottle of sweet dreams!
Playball has a warning on it.
Do not mix dangerous.
Mixing sweet dreams and night night is extremely dangerous for family.
Cannot be used with sprayer.
Oh, shit.
Look. Nothing seems out of the ordinary.
Looks like a normal beehive.
Can I open up the beehive?
These are just crawling around inside it silently.
Anything else?
We've got the stinky liquid.
Open the beehive.
These are just crawling around it silently.
No?
You know what?
Inside of the holes.
Okay, blah blah blah.
The corpse is clutching something in its hand.
I try to open the fingers.
Cottage key!
Cottage key. We got it!
When I put the key in my bag, my wrist burns in pain.
Mark burns scarlet.
Half an hour left until death closes in.
Time is a construct in this game.
And I'm going to spend way more!
Way longer!
I felt this before.
Both sweat drips down my back.
I suddenly remember what happened at age elementary.
The Mark's symptoms accelerated
and the person with me began acting strangely.
Hey, Kristie?
Spin around and look at them.
What?
The stairs at me puzzled.
Are you feeling okay?
Yes, I feel perfectly normal.
I need to hurry, you know.
Right.
It doesn't seem like she's changed at all.
I don't understand what's going on,
but if she's fine, that's great news.
New info was added to the Spirit Fire.
Human defile.
Okay, why?
Why can I not record now?
Why can I not?
Senpai!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the 5 super chat demand.
Why do the high bodies not have legs?
Where are their bees' knees?
I...
I disliked that.
Okay, now, can we use it now?
Use the Cottage Key to open the door.
An overly sweet smell
permeates the inside of the cottage.
Pretty sure it's...
Honey, huh?
Oh no, not again!
No! Not another body bag!
No!
My eyes fall on a white object
that was carelessly left lying around.
That can't be.
Aw...
Don't tell me...
You're thinking about opening that...
Have to check it out.
No, I don't!
No, I don't have to check it out!
We don't have much time left.
Well, I'm gonna grab everything else first.
Look.
Family won't die if they're dreaming.
Wake them and hit them.
Do it until they calm down.
Be careful, everyone.
When they wake up, family is only human.
Family won't die if they're dreaming.
Blah, blah, blah. Wake them up.
And hit them. Do it until they calm down.
I had to get... Okay, that's the hint!
Be careful, everyone.
It's like some useful information.
Should I rip it out and take it with me?
Yes! Take it!
More night night.
The bottle's a cracked damage.
I don't think I can use them. Fuck.
Inside of the container is corroded.
I don't think I can use it. Fuck!
It's a small container.
Ugly lady is written in faded marker.
Let's be someone ID of a prank.
Open the container.
Inside is something that looks like a dried tree root.
Fuck.
Dried root.
A scrap of paper stuck to the tree root with wire.
Everyone's gone.
I'm all alone now.
I want to see everyone.
My head is so foggy.
I can't remember how.
I think the last thing I need to do is combine those two.
But...
Oh my gosh.
Two what?
What are we gathering two of?
Root plus what?
Stinky liquid?
Reformed in a quiet place in the area past the meeting place.
What's the meeting place?
Is the meeting place the other way around?
I don't know if it's the right way.
Combine Night Night and Sweet Dreams maybe?
No, that's not right!
It has to be the root.
for mint honey get spanky liquid drawn by smell these enter high with family fun
play catch liquid got on sticky these gather over over game interrupted don't
know maybe it is root and honey maybe it's root and spanky liquid a big burlap
side sack is slung against the wall incredibly lumpy making it easy to
determine it's holding something just then something inside the bag
keep squirming intermittently why is it moving a cold sweat breaks out on my
forehead I hesitatingly reach for the mouth of the bag putting my breath I
slowly open it not again a secondingly sweet smell
hits us the corpse currently becoming a beehive no is that Kimura
it's completely unrecognizable at this point but I intuitively know who it is
Masao Kimura who was sitting on the bench was shimeo and wanted to commit
suicide this is one of my worst nightmares not gonna lie like yeah things
getting out of the holes body yeah gross
maybe they're burrowing into holes all over his body diligently making their
hind faint noise we heard came from the bag must have been the buzzing of beads
this is beyond saying has to be the work of shimeo once it's complete another
object art will be added to that repulsive beef farm just then I noticed
some objects stuffed next to the corpse mismatch item seems like burial
accessories for the dearly departed tennis ball large bottle of night night
night night times three thank you boy only moly yeah that's holy right
days the swarm then you'll be safe
days the swarm I do that with what I've found so far we return Masao's bar
corpse to the bag give him a proper burial but there's no time for that
right hey hey can I say something Christy's expression is grave your face
is flushed with shame I know full well that it's far too late to be saying
this but I can't stand it I can't take any more of us wait what if we've run
into this monster no way will I be able to do anything wait what I'm not getting
whatever I said on TV is totally meaningless here in this force sorry but
I can't help you anymore
I guess I have to go back I know this is out of the blue but I thought it was
now or never really I'm sorry but I just can't do this
as he stumbles over multiple apologies no there's nothing to apologize for normal
in situations like this any regular person would react the same oh everyone
would want to run as far as like the profession carries dangerous consequence
all of its own some pie thank you Jamie you got this call hi mini head pass thank
you for thank you so much thank you for the two fitty-two
if at some point I end up fighting the spirit like I did at age elementary
could she handle being my partner no she can't worry are going back and
changing people new info was added to spirit by the union with Kimura
well there's some more stuff here inside the small box but outside is covered in
something that's horribly picky
they're buggy novels they're unbeatable fuck okay we got to get out of here we're
gonna change we got to bring show back
shit
this is their direction right
well I can save here too thank the insulin punk with me
okay well that was kind of annoying well if I can do his funny voice after
was there anything in the front cuz I was thinking about like areas where they
were having you know where they were like oh what's this the end of the path of
meetings might be the area past the meeting place mentioned in the note
push through the undergrowth yeah this is where I was like you know meeting
places right kind of beast trail leading to the east
the ghost of a man stands blocking your way staring silently the figures
glaring harshly at both of us
hey that's over a show but there's probably nothing that can be done woman
woman woman woman woman woman immediately pushed back by a strong
no way ain't no fucking way I need Christy
I can't believe it Christy come back with me
just a second okay just a second okay
I can't fucking believe it
I just need you for one last thing and then I'll get the guys don't worry
okay don't spook me again I know you're there
ask your partner me I can't I can't do that but when she faces the figure and
offers up a prayer
why did that fucking work the figure vanishes
oh thank goodness I guess the ghost was glad to see a woman
I mean I get the I guess the goal the ghost was glad to see a woman
it's like my prayer got through to it then prayers come in handy sometimes huh
let's keep going
is there anything around here
what's this
looks like the flower was blooming the leaves are distinctly pointed
the plant is inspected but nothing seems out of ordinary about it
fruit is still firmly lodged in the soil playing on it does nothing
maybe I can use a tool on it doesn't look like it's being used
anymore there aren't any bees anywhere
hopefully open it up the side is a photo scrap of paper it's something that
looks like incense got suicide note mosquito repelling incense
well what does it fucking say
like the teachings apple honey manage to swallow it wait for me everyone I'll be
there soon
I dig it out with like the broken crowbar
it got the broken crowbar and pressed in the dirt by the plant
dirt is softer than I expected the pointed end
usually breaks it up if I only get to the root it's kind of like a
small carrot but that root
huh why are you going to do with that I don't fucking know
I guess that was the meeting
there was a thing to mix with the root right yeah
I don't actually know senpai we have to probably read the thing again
okay we turn back to kujo mansion we get show this time
but that is voice
let's look at my notes
okay
sticky liquid
performed holy journey quiet place area past the meeting place a clue on how to
get to paradise
filled with liquid dripping from a corpse smells bitter
sweet and extremely thick this is probably what attracts the ease
sweet dreams do not make dangerous not compatible sprayer
old key found in the hand cottage is legible
item torn from a book family won't die if they're dreaming when the portrayer
comes wake them up and hit them do it until they calm down be careful when
they wake up family is only human
um dried plant root found in a small box labeled ugly lady small papers
attached with the wire saying I think the last thing I need to do is combine
these two okay I guess we keep on hitting them
until they calm down I guess
um
I guess something found in the bag holding
mass cell humorous corpse it's wet and some kind of liquid
and it's stained arch bottle of mystery medicine we got the mystery man
mission
how do we deal with some pie when he tries to escape
hammers okay night night more night night night night night night
okay
suicide note like the teachings apple honey managed to swallow it wait for me
everyone i'll be there soon in a plant root looks like a carrot
what's this what's the difference between dried root and plant root
I don't know the difference
that's kind of is it the sticky liquid then we have to mix it with
water
um
There might be more notes to find.
Probably.
We got a show, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, what's the other place that we didn't go to?
Because I was like, OK, that was like an empty area.
So we got that.
We got our homie.
What's the tool? Yeah.
OK, but now we have more night night.
So if we go forward.
Here.
Yeah.
And we go here and then turn left, right?
No, we did not.
It's great.
Great.
Yeah.
Was it right?
No.
Uh.
It's great.
I think I was here.
Yeah, let's go.
Yeah.
Let's spray with night night.
Yeah, take careful aim and spray the drug.
OK, the bees movement got slower.
Eventually, the high falls completely silent.
Used up one bottle of night night.
I've silenced every hive in the area.
Now we can pass through.
They're all dead.
I don't think so.
I think they're all sleeping, right?
Jesus.
Fucking hate this.
Nothing.
Damn, thanks for the thanks for the sound.
OK.
Three of women corpses that's been turned into hives.
The buzz of bees fill the air.
And look, the drug should easily be able to reach it.
Actually, wait, I'm too close.
We shouldn't breathe in the stuff.
I touched this.
The drugs should easily be able to reach it.
Drugs.
No, I can't think of a way to use it.
What do we use, Senpai?
There might be something back in the shed again.
I don't think so.
The sticky liquid?
Doesn't that attract bees?
Sweet dreams?
No.
It's too big.
Maybe another night night?
OK.
I used up one bottle and night night.
Shit, I'm low on night night.
Nothing seems out of ordinary.
Looks like a normal beehive.
A lot of drugs fit inside the beehive.
Good morning.
I don't know why, like, scanning.
It was like, we're too close for drugs.
Uses drugs anyways.
Shit.
Mark has died in a deep crimson.
A few minutes left until death closes in.
Aw, shit.
The mark scorches me again.
It's like we're out of time.
I face myself like Lance over at show.
Show.
I'm counting on you.
Why are you...
I...
What were we supposed to mix?
I didn't have...
Aw, I don't have it.
Sorry, this is going to hurt.
I slap show's face.
Ow!
Oh, man, you little...
Near your head a little.
Coming.
We have to go.
We'll do everything we can,
but you have to do as I say.
Yeah, okay.
I proceed to lead show into the darkness.
Where was I supposed to go?
Shit!
Gifting on the wind from somewhere
is the meltingly sweet fragrance of honey.
New info was added to the spirit file.
Tracing female.
Fuckin' bees!
Oh, hi!
Something flies at us in the dark.
Sharp paint pierces the arm I used to cover my face.
I think I got stung by a bee.
I don't know how to do this,
but he said hit him, right?
Was...
Sorry, senpai.
Was that loud sound from the game,
or was that something from upstairs?
Oh, my gosh.
Bees swarm around chimio.
As he draws closer,
I won't survive being attacked again.
Just worry that mama.
Okay, give me a second.
Sorry.
Sorry, senpai.
I'm just gonna double check to make sure
that mama, mama, and papa are okay.
I'll be back, okay?
It's okay to leave it like this, right?
Okay, hold on.
Just be right back.
Okay.
Sorry, senpai.
There's a big storm outside,
like super big storm,
like lightning everywhere.
So I think
I'm gonna have to cut it pretty short today
because I don't think it's a good idea
to like have my computer on
and if it like,
you know, if the lightning does it,
does like hit something,
I don't wanna lose any data
or like ride my computer.
So it's like huge storm right now
and the sound that I heard was actually like thunder,
like really loud thunder.
I was like, holy fuck.
So yeah, I'm gonna do this real quick
and then we'll have to cut it short.
Short.
Sorry, senpai.
Okay.
I won't survive being attacked either.
It must be pretty close, yeah.
Fuck, I don't know.
Um...
Fuck.
Uh...
Baseball!
And uh...
Baseball bat.
No, spear's too far away to try this.
Never mind.
Uh...
Night night.
And...
No.
Good morning?
Sticky liquids?
Sticky liquids.
Okay.
You want stinky liquids, senpai?
And what else?
What else should we do?
Stinky liquid and...
And what?
Baseball?
We...
Apply the liquid to the baseball?
And then just be like, yay!
I guess we can do that.
Yeah, that's gonna work.
Yeah, let's throw it!
And pour the stinky liquid over...
Stinky liquid over the tennis ball and throw it.
Timo incites the bee.
The bee's cloud rush at the ball.
Must be reacting to the smell of the liquid on it.
Bee's form the ball.
They look like a dense black cloud.
Okay, okay, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
Uh, shit.
Liquid again.
And uh...
The baseball.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm waiting.
Waiting senpai.
He's a little...
Close?
Yeah?
He's not close yet.
Should we hit him?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
I want to make this quick.
Bees aren't coming back, right?
Well, maybe.
I don't know how many bees he has.
We should use something else?
He's not close enough yet.
Whatever, I'm going to do it again.
We have two of them, so we're going to do it twice.
Yeah, yeah, we need...
We can't hit him yet because he's not close enough yet.
Yeah, fuck it.
Throw the ball.
Yeah.
Chimmyo incites the bees.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, yeah, yeah, okay, it's true.
The bee cloud rushes at the ball again.
I just remembered the last one.
I guess the second ball was effective too.
Oh, gosh, you're ugly.
Okay, uh, we were very close.
Fuck.
I have two of these.
Can we wake the bees up again?
We hit him, right?
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm so glad that we can still do this.
Hold on.
We're not mixed.
Dangerous.
Wake them up and hit them.
Okay, I think that one's right.
Yeah, wake them up and hit them.
Yeah.
I cut open the body and a bitter sweet smelling liquid pours out.
Oh, I am not a traitor.
Chimmyo bends over backwards moaning liquid sprays from the holes in his body.
Chimmyo falters.
Do we do it again?
I'm gonna do it again.
I'm gonna fucking do it again.
Spray Chimmyo with the drug and hit him with the base on that.
Chimmyo is wounded.
Chimmyo rides in pain.
His body jiggling.
Oh, I don't want to wake up.
Chimmyo hollers in pain as he gets hit,
but this doesn't seem enough to beat him.
Chimmyo is weak.
Chimmyo is clearly weak.
Now's the time to finish him off.
Give me a second.
Are we going for the bad end or good end?
Hopefully good end!
I gotta check the notes though.
Where's the notes?
That one.
Which route? Which route?
Which route?
A plan with something.
I don't know.
I don't know what I need.
We need to wake him up, right?
What jar of honey?
We don't have a jar of honey!
You want this route?
And this route?
Two routes!
Both routes!
Let's go!
Is it going to work?
Darling throws the route into Chimmyo's mouth.
It was infected.
Chimmyo slowly munches on the dried root
and with a loud gulp, smalls it.
This isn't enough.
It's really not enough.
I don't know what to do.
It's not really noticing.
It's different.
It doesn't seem effective.
Fuck!
What about the dried...
dried root?
Let's just act it.
Lunches on the dried root
will allow gulp, smalls it.
Ah, shit.
Weakened by the attack,
Chimmyo shakes but musters the lock of the screen.
Ah, shit.
What? Where is the honey?
Beesworm out of holes in Chimmyo's body
and spring his entire body.
RIP me.
My vision darkens.
I can see the spirit slowly drawing closer.
Game over.
And unfortunately,
because that is a game over,
I have to probably go down.
We ended on a loss!
We need to find the honey, I guess.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, actually, this is what I need.
Save.
Ah, wait.
Yeah, I need to save.
Save.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, I need to end.
Here.
We'll come back, we'll get him.
Sorry about that, everyone.
I was so sure that we'll have things,
but I can literally Senpai.
I saw my lights flash,
so I think we gotta go.
I think we gotta go.
So...
Oof, let's make this real quick.
Thank you, everyone, for joining me today.
I'm so sorry that suddenly,
like, it's super thundery and stuff,
so we gotta go.
Yeah, the stream has been stuttering for me
for the last 30 minutes or so.
Okay, it might be because of the storm outside.
So, we're gonna just go really quickly
over my schedule, remaining schedule.
I only have one more day.
So, tomorrow I have day off.
Friday is my members' only stream.
I saw some new members here.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to thank you quick enough
because the members actually went too fast by.
But thank you so much for all those who member.
Remember, if you are on the members' tier,
you will have access to the stream.
We are playing SMT Nocturne.
Also known as Shin Megami Tensei Nocturne,
very, very fun game.
We're going to study a lot of the folk lords
and all the creatures in it.
And so, yeah, we'll have a lot of fun with that,
and I hope it will be memberable for you.
So, with that, let me quickly see who's on.
Hopefully, someone is on so I can send you guys there.
I think Mimosa is doing an 8-hour gaming thing.
So, we'll send you over to Mimosa.
Since Mimosa is trying to get monetization.
Let's everyone cheer Mimosa on, Okidoki.
Oh, I can hear the thunder.
I hear the thunderbutton lightning.
So, I'll see you guys again next time.
And remember, scream for mercy!
Bye-bye!